although it's lovely to see his dirty
flicks and [ __ ] and we're going to be
talking about your role in the Christmas
special of Doctor Who now you play a
galactic nun I believe tell us more I do
play a galactic nun and Tasha LEM is
somebody who is from the doctors past
she's an old friend of his and in this
episode he comes to her for help we have
not met Tasha before but we have met her
forces we've met the troops of the papal
mainframe in a former episode and this
is the big boss she's she's the mother
superious as she's called of the papal
mainframe she's extraordinarily powerful
so she's like the head of the Galactic
UN she's a peacekeeping force but
they've got more firepower and more
willingness to use that than the earthly
UN so they are kind of a scary outfit if
you were on the wrong side of them but
and I think he has to feel that she will
help them and indeed she will because
she's an old friend of his what did you
enjoy most about playing Tasha LEM I
particularly enjoyed aside obviously
from working with Matt and Jenna who
were just you know a lovely people but
more importantly they do what they're
doing very very well they both they both
love what they're doing they both are
hugely enthusiastic matters it's it's as
if it's his first week at work so he's
you know he's there
looking at every scene seeing what he
can get out of us really really finding
you know the heart the comedy the
moments in it there's no sitting back on
the part so that was a really great
thing to be around a lovely thing to
work with and I think my purse in a
little highlight moment was getting to
do a scene with Daleks yeah it's sort of
like visiting your childhood nightmares
because you as a child
do you remember moving away from the
telly you see them and you'd be you know
and you'd hide behind somebody and I
remember thinking well
obviously that's a long time ago and
I'll see these ten things and I just
think Oh pathetic but in fact when they
came in they move quite quickly and
there is this voice you know this this
wonderful voice and I actually felt
myself watching to move away slightly so
I was quite fond - I mean you mentioned
kind of reliving childhood memories zone
and with the Daleks a particular scary
villain for you from the show when you
were a kid then were they well they are
the archetypal baddies you know this
kind of totalitarian regime that they
represent is is something that is
there's something about death there's
something just deadening and about death
and about no mercy as they say
themselves there's something that you
feel there's no ability to reason with
them and that's terrifying of course at
any age but it's certainly terrifying as
a child and so you bring a certain part
of that with you don't you into
adulthood not just a Dalek from the show
though I mean we've got a plethora of
villain lúcia we've got the weeping
angels you do we've got the silence
we've also got Cybermen as well yeah
what was it like kind of being around
when things like that were being shot
well the thing is I was interested that
exist in time so I couldn't be around
for all the shooting obviously you're in
some days and not in other days and some
of the time I had to remove myself to go
and do a particular makeup so I'd love
to watch the Cybermen and and I couldn't
be around for that I saw them wandering
when I was outside having a [ __ ] but I
didn't kind of see them for the shooting
and obviously the silence are part of or
become part of the papal mainframe so I
did have scenes where a silence were
present and have a certain allegiance to
me so that was fine I hung out with my
Bros the silence
so really the one and the weeping angels
was a different whole set of scenes that
I couldn't be around I find them
terrifying really terrifying blink was
one of those episodes that you really
really jump back and this is obviously
not as a child you really there's
something we think oh that's very good
because it's about something you can't
see
so the concept of it just work
beautifully on it so what I love matter
is it's so low-tech it doesn't take some
big explosion I mean obviously they just
move the statutes but there's something
great about the fact that you look back
and something else has happened so I
found the weeping angels terrifying but
I didn't have to didn't have to work
with them when you're kind of glad in
that case that you didn't have to work
with well I'll tell you here's the thing
is I'm supposed to be although I'm on
the side of broadly speaking you know
I'm on the side of good I'm supposed to
be not frightening but but authoritative
you're supposed to believe that she can
run these troops and run the silence and
run this giant ship and run the UN of
space and that she will use her fire
power if necessary because she does get
cross shall we say with the doctor at a
certain point because of course she's
used to troops and pretty much being
under her control and doing what she
asks of them and she does ask the doctor
to do a particular thing and he's a bit
of a loose cannon and he kind of goes
rogue so she's not best pleased at a
certain point I know you a newbie to
talk to here in a way exciting you watch
it's a kid but you kind of caught up on
all the doctor who lured in for this
yeah I had to pick up on a lot of
strands from math shows and a series in
the past the Steven Moffat said in this
so how was that
getting to grips with all the background
oh well look it was great because I am
obviously wanted to and had to do my
research to find out what the what the
story strand was because there are
things that I'm I get to kind of explain
reasonably briefly in the in this
episode and so I asked the editor for
you know that the key stories that would
relate to what just to talk about and
watch those and thought that I would
just watch five or six
since it have be done and over that five
or six in my rainy hotel room in Cardiff
I became this cuvee and I sort of went
into the room as just a normal person
and then kind of emerged two days later
with red eyes and a kind of new passion
for Doctor Who you know there were
moments there were episodes that are
just standalone they're extraordinary
blinkers obviously one of them and Hyde
is a beautiful piece the empty child is
extraordinarily scary and spooky and
funnily enough I think this must be a
thing of mine but I'm going back to all
the low-tech things if you notice the
things that aren't about some huge
effects because it's more that you
create an atmosphere by telling a story
a certain way and in all those instances
they were proposing an idea and
something that makes us fearful but we
don't know why but it makes us
uncomfortable so they were great kind of
psychological dramas and they were also
standalone in a way that some of the
some of the Doctor Who stuff you kind of
want to be part of the ongoing story but
it is remarkably easy to watch single
episodes and and they're they're very
satisfying and these are just very good
examples of that I mean how far did you
kind of construct a backstory it was a
back story in that they have they enjoy
each other's company she's a little bit
of a loose cannon and kind of says
everything in the room that he's kind of
trying to tell her to maybe don't say
that in front of everybody you know so
to that extent we invented what was
between us you go incredible look as
well waste strong a look to the
characters all kind of Blade Runner a
short we seen other yeah yeah that was
that was them again that was suggested
by Jamie paying the director he he he
referenced that and I think what he was
he was trying to feel from her was a
slightly slightly otherworldly thing
she's human but Steven Moffat said she's
a descendent of humans it's like there's
some element of her that is not quite
just human like you or I am this she
doesn't have specific superpowers much
to my huge disappointment yeah I didn't
get to fly or anything
but there is an element of it there's a
strain of something else something alien
I've come in obviously I have invented
an entire storyline and series around
Tasha laughs obviously I bet everybody
who goes on the show thinks oh you know
what
wouldn't it be great if because it's
just an enjoyable show to do I mean
that's the thing is it's there is no
downside there couldn't be a downside to
to doing Doctor Who you your I when I
got the script I it came in I got a call
to play it and I kind of was busy
working I was shooting that day and
shooting hard for a few days so didn't
have time to read it immediately and I
just said look it'll be a yes I will
read it of course in the next day or two
but it'll be a yes and my agent was
saying well are you sure don't you want
to read a person I said what do you know
what what's it gonna be you know it's
going to be a sort of you know and
phosphorescent chicken who speaks
Russian or a cyborg bottom or something
I'm game you know that's fine it turns
out it was taschlin which is lovely and
you know I was very pleased with the
character but it's just it's a lovely
party to be invited to so I was I was
very happy to turn up and whatever
costume they wanted me to turn up in and
be at that party and of course your
friend mr. Sarah parish was also in a
Christmas actually we met at something
and we're talking about this and we
suddenly realized there's somebody kind
of listening and looking at his boat and
thinking why are they talking about
being galactic nuns and red spiders and
you know I thought they did drama and
they hadn't quite kind of twigged what
the doctor who experience was but ya
know she had a ball on it and I had to
blow on us I mean what can you say what
are your favorite you know there are
moments that you think will be just
another day shooting but you feel
slightly overwhelmed going on the TARDIS
you know I don't know why but again it's
something you've been watching since
so there's something about that so just
walking onto the TARDIS I just felt a
little bit overwhelmed I had to kind of
look around and take a moment and then
we rehearsed and then we just did the
scene as you do but it was it had the
effect of when you meet somebody famous
or you see the Taj Mahal for the first
time really rather than in a picture and
that was it it was just so known to me
and then I was on it looking around so
that felt a bit magical of course the
Christmas specials all about saying
farewell to Matt Smith so how did you
feel that they balance that saying
goodbye to Matt with welcoming in the
new doctor first of all they balanced
and the kind of darkness at the end of
his story because it has been predicted
for a long time that as you know he has
it has been predicted that he will die
in trenzalore and that appears to be it
will it is where this story is going so
there is a kind of darkness and a
sadness and we know he's going we know
this is happening that is woven together
very beautifully and very skillfully
with a very Christmassy episode and it
really is beautifully done so there is
that kind of that M emotion around
Christmas Day as where's the emotion of
him leaving and there's also a kind of
an appropriate sadness around it you
know that thing that at Christmas
there's a sadness around Christmas
sometimes because of our set of
expectations around it and our set of
expectations around things being perfect
and being with people you love and so on
as often doesn't work out as you would
have it in your dreams so there's
something lovely about that kind of mix
up together and look I think it's hard
for any new doctor coming in it just is
hard I'm sure it was hard for David
Tennant I'm sure it was hard for Matt
coming in you know after David and it'll
be hard for Peter because there is a
doctor that everyone knows and loves and
they're leaving and you can't help but
be sad about that but I kind of think a
you can you can be in love with more
than one person and I think that already
everyone is understanding how right
Peter is I mean the moment it was
announced he just thought of course you
didn't remotely think Oh interest in
casting or anything like that you just
thought of
corsets Peter Capaldi he's the doctor of
course he is so already I feel it's it's
just it's accepted and he'll be
wonderful he'll be really really
wonderful you know in his own way and
one of the things people ask you a lot
of people get our starters you know
who's the best doctor and it's just it's
a bad question because there isn't a
best and worst Ohr there's just some
doctors resonate for you more like a
poem does like a book does a song does
I'll stop now and but there are certain
doctors that you know you you just
respond to more that you kind of feel
they you know they brought out things
that you wanted to see in the doctor and
matt has very clearly done a absolutely
beautiful job over the last few years
and he will be missed but Peter will
Peter will win the hearts of the world
it was a special that's right he was
lovely I mean we it was you know was a
short it was a week you you rehearsed
all week and then you did it in front of
a live audience and listen he's all the
things you know about him he's very
funny and he's very nice he's a
fantastic actor and he's got he's got
this kind of quality that is so right
for Doctor Who which is he's got a kind
of he's got a slightly scary quality in
one said he's got a stature about him
where there's a kind of Quicksilver
quality they can go here or go there and
you don't quite know but he's also so
able to be funny and you know this
somebody having all those qualities at
once that's quite hard to hit all those
things together and both the actors were
talking about Matt and Peter have that
in spades absolutely in spades so he'll
be he'll be wonderful and yeah I wish
I'd got I wish I'd got to you know we
didn't obviously do a scene together in
this because that's after the
regeneration but I'd love to have
because he's he's a good guy to work
with Steven Moffat said recently that
we're not actually on the 11th stopped
with Matt he's actually the 13th doctor
because we've got John Hurt now and also
David Tennant had two generations so
what does this mean for Peter Capaldi me
wonder what would you like to see happen
I just want the series
go on forever so obviously what I don't
want is some sort of massive you know
practical joke where Matt dies and they
go yeah no that's it we were just joking
about Peter Andrew who's over here we
just riots would break out God actually
slightly sweaty thinking about that
clearly there's something up because
he's not it forward to that so clearly
he wants to kind of not wait to do that
he wants to kind of get on that the fact
that we're getting to the end of the
regeneration cycle so he said he has
done something in the script although
it's been lovely talking to today and
hearing about the excitement of the
Doctor Who Christmas special we cannot
wait to see I hope you enjoy it very
much you do
you